[Musique]
mardi 30 janvier bonsoir et bienvenue
dans le C sur tv78 voici les titres de
l'actualité le mouvement des
agriculteurs se durcit depuis hier il
bloque les grands axe autour de Paris
pour alerter sur leur situation c'est le
cas dans les ivelines notamment sur
l'autoroute à 13 au niveau de Mantel non
content des annonces du Premier ministre
Gabriel hatal lors de son discours de
politique générale les agriculteurs se
rapprochent ce soir de la capitale et
font route vers le triangle de rencour
ont fait le point en début d'édition il
y a quelques jours le président de la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
Versailles Eveline Guillaume kerou
présentait ses vœux au chefs
d'entreprise du département création de
sociétés embauche perspective quels sont
les objectifs et les prévisions pour
2024 après une année 2023 marquée par
l'inflation élément de réponse comme
tous les mardis Maxens de la croué jeune
yvelinois passionné d'histoire vous en
apprend plus sur le département ce soir
Maxens nous parle de la méconnue mais
non moins importante bataille de r
encour en 1815 et puis l'invité du 78 en
2è partie d'émission ce soir la dernière
de nos interviews avec les maires de 50
ans en Eveline ALIR rabe sera avec nous
le maire de Trapp nous parlera des
grands dossiers de 2024 dans sa commune
et j'accueille tout de suite Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir bonsoir gr tion TV 78 et
juste avant de faire le point sur la
situation concernant la colère des
agriculteurs on va faire le point avec
vous sur le reste des actualités du
jour aujourd'hui Gabriel avait lieu à
plaisir une première journée
départementale des réussites éducatives
des Yvelines en quoi ça consistait et
bien oui une journée organisée par
l'académie de Versailles et la
préfecture desvelin l'objectif grégoryi
de cette journée faire rencontrer les
différents acteurs de l'éducation du
département afin de penser l'école de
demain alors plusieurs Tabl rondes
étaient organisé sur différentes
thématiques comme construire et
entretenir les liens avec les parents ou
encore accompagner la réussite de tous
les jeunes un moment privilégié de
rencontrre et d'échange pour les acteurs
de l'éducation on les écoute nous
croyons beaucoup dans l'alliance
éducative de tous les acteurs au service
des enfants qu'il relève de l'éducation
nationale de la préfecture des communes
nous nous voyons très fréquemment dans
les quartiers pour dans le cadre des
cités éducatives dans le C des
programmes de réussite éducative bref
dans le cadre de divers dispositifs mais
c'était important d'avoir ce temps
départemental pour rassembler tout ce t
tous ces acteurs de l'éducation
l'intérêt c'est d'avoir aussi une vision
globale comment intervenir de façon
globale et de structurer ces outils et
c'est pour cela qu'on a développer
autour des programmes de REC éducative
aussi la la logique de cité éducative
qui est un dispositif d'intégration qui
réunit autour de la table tous les
acteurs éducation nationale collectivité
locale association qui interviennent
autour dans le temps scolaire et autour
du temps scolaire vers les enfants vers
les élèves alors journée également de
rencontrre de discussion cette fois-ci
au Vélodrome nationale de 5 an en
Yveline et c'était sur la thématique du
sport avec l'UVSQ l'université de
Versailles 5ant an en neline qui a
organisait son 5e et dernier symposium
sport santé oui et pour l'occasion
grégoryi l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yveline avait réuni sa
communauté universitaire mais aussi le
grand public au programme conférence et
table ronde sur la thématique sport et
santé des étudiants mais aussi des
activités de découverte des disciplines
olympiques comme le BMX ou encore le
break dance à l'approche des Jeux de
Paris 2024 cette journée était placée
sous le signe de l'olympisme l'événement
se terminera avec la traditionnelle
cérémonie des vœux du président de
l'UVSQ et vous pourrez retrouver un
reportage complet sur cet événement dans
le prochain numéro du skycho on va
prendre des nouvelles des bus dans le
sud Yveline on avait mis en lumière ses
dysfonctionnements concernant le service
des bus Transdev autour des communes de
Chevreuse et de léi saintnon est-ce que
la situation s'est améliorée Gabriel et
bien oui pour pour rappel hein depuis
début janvier la date de reprise du
transporteur Transdev le service des bus
est fortement perturbé parmi les
problématiques on le rappelle grégoryi
des arrêts non desservis mettant en
difficulté les collégiens et donnant
lieu à des situations parfois absurdes
comme lorsque certains maires des
communes touchées s'improvisent taxi
pour les élèves face à la colère des
élus Valérie pcres présidente
d'île-de-fance mobilité a annoncé la
mise en deme de Transdev dénonçant une
situation inacceptable elle demande aux
transporteurs le respect du contrat sous
peine d'un retrait de la délégation du
service public selon nos confrères de
cette Hite actu on termine avec une
information qui concerne le festival
Electric Park à Chatou oui attention si
vous aviez pris vos places pour
l'édition 2024 vous allez devoir revoir
votre organisation en raison des jeux
olympique et paralympique la
programmation et la date de l'événement
doit changer si le festival était
programmé cette année les 30 et 31 août
2024 il se tiendra finalement sur une
seule journée et ce sera le 15 juin
prochain ce changement fait suite à une
décision tardife du préfet de police de
Paris qui a demandé aux organisateurs de
changer la date du festival pour des
raison de sécurité à noté tout de même
grégoryi que les passes de jours seront
bien évidemment remboursées merci
beaucoup Gabriel et si vous aussi prê de
chez vous vous êtes témoins d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
Yvelines n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news à suivre point de situation sur la
colère des agriculteurs on vous rappelle
he cette information dont nous vous
parlions en début d'édition les
agriculteurs qui font route ce soir vers
le triangle de recancour il se rapproche
de la capitale il Contin continuent leur
mouvement de contestation Noncent des
dernières annonces du Premier ministre
Gabriel Atal on va faire le point sur la
situation dans un instant mais juste
avant la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie versaill Eveline présentait
ses vœux à Versailles il y a quelques
jours pour l'occasion plus de 300
institutionnels chefs d'entreprise et
jeunes porteur de projet étit présent
l'occasion pour eux de dresser les
perspectives économiques de l'année 2024
dans le département le reportage de
Clara de Frutos l'industrie l'emploi et
la jeunesse étent à l'honneur mercredi
24 janvier à la Chambre des commerces et
d'industrie des ivelines lors de sa
cérémonie des vœux l'organisme a
notamment présenté ses perspectives pour
la nouvelle année 2024 pour créer
davantage d'entreprises dans territoire
il faut des ambassadeurs il faut les
entreprises industrielles on est dans un
territoire d'industrie et il faut les
entreprises qui puissent innover donc on
a voilà de jeunes ingénieurs de jeunes
scientifiques on vise plus de 30000
création entreprise dans not territoire
pour 2024 plus de 300 institutionnels
chefs d'entreprise et jeunes porteurs de
projet étai rassemblés à l'Hôtel Du
Barry de versaill parmi eux Sébastien R
directeur des ressources humaines du
site de production Renault afflin pour
qui l'année 2024 sera notamment consacré
à l'embauche nous avons d'ors et déjà
annoncé que l'année 2024 serait le début
d'un cycle qui nous verrait passer à 150
nouveaux emplois en CDI pour accompagner
la croissance de la rifactory et ses
nouvelles activités le site de la
refifactory de Flin pour Renault group
ça représente un enjeu nouveau autour du
thème de l'économie circulaire de la
mobilité et c'est aussi un élément qui
est majeur pour les nouvelles
générations et donc à ce titre nous
souhaitons parler aux nouvelles
générations et attirer les nouveaux
talents l'économie circulaire un enjeu
également fondamental pour hugoline
solaire fondatrice de reknorec basée à
traap la start-up transforme les
plastiques orphelins de solution de
recyclage en un matériau solide et
écologique qui se travaille comme du
bois 2024 c'est une année extraordinaire
pour nous c'est l'année du décollage
c'est l'année du démarrage de la
production industrielle attendu depuis
un certain temps donc là en janvier on
démarre on a l'ambition de sauver 100
tonnes de déchets orphelins cette année
avant de pouvoir multiplier les impacts
et les territoires d'implantation en
2023 la chambre des commerces et
d'industrie des ivblines a accompagné
près de 25800 entreprises et 8400
établissement l'an passé près d'une
trentaine de collectivités territoriales
et neuf hôpitaux dont André Mignot
chénéau cancour ont été victime d'une
cyberattaque pourtant le secteur de la
cybersécurité fait face à une une
pénurie de talent une pénurie de talent
c'est une carence he de de ces nouveaux
talents dont les entreprises ont
pourtant besoin interview avec le
directeur général adjoint de l'école
2600 qui est basée à 50 ans en yeline
établissement forme au métier de la
cybersécurité les propos recueillis par
Aurélie
[Musique]
lafeille on remarque que ce secteur a du
mal à rassembler et à engager des
talents on parle environ de 15000 postes
non pourvus en France 300 à 500000 en
Europe malgré une politique
gouvernementale qui vise sur 4 ans à
doubler le nombre d'emplois entre 2021
et 2025 ce qu'on remarque c'est qu'il y
a une une réelle difficulté pour les
personnes
à être up to date par rapport aux
menaces le monde de la cyber est un
monde qui est en constante mutation donc
on a besoin d'avoir des personnes qui
puisse répondre de manière très rapide à
cela dans le casadre de la formation
initiale nous avons donc 270 étudiants
qui sont en alternance dans 250
entreprises différentes entreprises qui
évoluent sur des thématiques aux
alentours de la sécurité défensive de la
sécurité offensive ou de la gouvernance
l'entreprise a investi sur lui
nécessairement elle a envie de le garder
et de continuer à le valoriser et à le
faire monter en
compétence
[Musique]
nous avons à 2600 une double approche la
première pour tout ce qui concerne la
formation continue c'est-à-dire la
formation à court terme nous allons
mettre en place une plateforme qui sera
lancée pour la rentrée 2024 dont le
fonctionnement est assez disruptif
puisqu'il vise la certification de
microocométences l'intérêt pour les
entreprises est simple s'assurer d'avoir
de l'skilling ou du rskill ou du
reskilling parmi leur personnel pour
avoir des experts ou des praticiens de
la cybersécurité qui
soit tout à fait prêt à répondre aux
problématiques
[Musique]
rapidement on ouvre une page culture
dans le
[Musique]
78 une soirée rock et pop un voyage
entre Orient et Occident une
redécouverte des plus grands tubes
britanniques c'est ce que propose la
batterie de guyancour le 3 février
prochain sur scène d Yaman et Adrian
Clarc trio voici trois raisons d'y aller
c'est au micro de Mathilde Francou
bonjour je m'appelle Benjamin guilla je
suis responsable des relations avec les
publics et de l'action culturelle pour
les scènes de Guill encours aujourd'hui
je vais vous présenter trois bonnes
raisons de vous rendre à la batterie et
plus précisément à l'auditorium de la
batterie pour assister à un concert avec
deux groupes dyaman et Adrian Clark
[Musique]
trio première raison c'est une occasion
rare d'assister à un concert pop rock
dans cette SLE l'auditorium de la
batterie qui est habituellement dédié
aux musique classique ou au Jaz et cette
salle est appréciée pour ses qualités
acoustiques le confort des sièges et la
proximité qu'elle permet entre le public
et les artistes la seconde raison tient
au répertoire emprunté au Beatles Queen
le répertoire pop rock notamment la pop
rock britannique qui est revisité par
des arrangements audacieux par les
musiciens donc de Adrian Clark trio
musicien et chanteuse jazz
[Musique]
aguéri la trè raison c'est de prolonger
la soirée avec la musique captivante et
ensorcelante de
delaman c'est difficile de classer la
musique de del Yaman entre pop rock
Dream rock
rock enfin bref c'est une musique qui a
un caractère cinématographique et qui a
qui sa'est d'ailleurs prêter au
[Musique]
cinéma c'était les TR bonnes raisons
d'aller voiran et Adri cl trio
l'auditorium de la batterie le samedi 3
février à
[Musique]
20h30 comme tous les mardis Maxens de la
croué jeune yvelinois passionné
d'histoire vous en apprend plus sur le
département et ce soir Maxens nous parle
de la méconnue mais non moins importante
bataille de rencour en 1815 la bataille
de r encour est absente de nos manuels
scolaires elle mérite cependant d'être
connue voici
pourquoi
1815 signe la fin de la domination
napoléonienne sur l'Europe le 20 mars
Napoléon s'évade de l'île d'Elbe pour
tenter de reprendre le pouvoir en France
mais la suite on la connaît le 18 juin
il est défait à Waterloo mais tout n'est
pas fini et ça personne ne s'en souvient
le 1er juillet les troupes françaises
ont décidé de venger Napoléon contraint
à abdiquer quelques jours plus tôt elles
attendaient le signal d'une bataille
comme une revanche de waterloot les
hussards prussiens se sentent en danger
et tentent de fuir vers l'ouest de la
capitale ils traversent Versailles en
passant par la place d'armes ou encore
l'avenue de Paris et arrivve jusqu'à la
petite ville de rauencour ils sont pris
en embuscade par un bataillon français
qui arrivait de ville d'avra les
Prussiens sont fusillés à bout portant
ils tentent de rebrousser chemin vers le
chînet mais ils finissent par être
encerclés sur les 1500 Prussiens environ
1000 furent tués ou fait prisonnier le
reste parvenant à s'échapper ce bilan
démontre bien une large victoire des
forces napoléoniennes qui voulaient
souffrir un dernier succès avant de voir
le Premier Empire
disparaître
et le hasard de l'actualité nous amène à
parler de nouveau de rencour puisque les
agriculteurs se rapprochent du triangle
de rencour ils se rapprochent même de la
capitale ils sont mobilisés depuis
plusieurs jours pour alerter sur leur
situation ils ont décidé de durcir le
mouvement et ce après les annonces du
Premier ministre Gabriel hatal c'était
cet après-midi le compte n'y est
toujours pas pour eux les agriculteur
qui bloqua la 13 au niveau du page de
bûchelet font donc route ce soir vers le
triangle de recancour le point sur la
situation avec Nicolas d'Andri et
Patrick Jacques de dixmud nous faisons
partie de l'opération siège de la
capitale mais nous sommes loin de la
capitale donc décision a été prise pour
qu'on nous écoute un petit peu plus de
se rapprocher de la
capitale
bravo 24 heur après le blocage de la 13
sur le PA de bchelet les agriculteurs
ont décidé de durcir le mouvement
d'après nos informations et d'après
l'assemblée générale qui s'est tenu
juste à l'instant avec les agriculteurs
yvelinois et du département de l'UR les
agriculteurs ont décidé de s'avancer
vers Paris direction le triangle de
rquencour une décision qui fait suite et
bien au discours de politique générale
du Premier ministre cet après-midi
Gabriel Atal a fait plusieurs annonces
concernant les agriculteurs mais il
semblerait que c'est soit insuffisant
aujourd'hui euh on s'aperçoit qu'on n
pas vraiment écouté
euh on a à peine parlé de nous enfin au
niveau de du gouvernement euh là je vois
un panneau au-dessus où il y a marqué
Porte Maillot plus 13 minutes donc en
fait euh aujourd'hui euh si on embête
pas les gens hein notre métier c'est pas
d'embêter les gens mais si on les embête
pas on n'est pas écouté on n'est pas
pris au sérieux donc on a voulu faire de
la communication en se mettant ici sans
embêter les gens ou un minimum et
aujourd'hui on n pas écouté donc et ben
on avance vers la capitale c'est
l'opération c'est siège de la capitale
on avance vers la
capitale et vous le voyez derrière moi
les agriculteurs commencent à
s'organiser pour déménager et bien de
bûchel parce qu'ils s'étaient très bien
organisé ils avaient notamment mis en
place des tables plusieurs barbecue il y
a même un foood truck où il pouvaient
s'alimenter il y a des dortoire aussi
pour dormir bref ils avaient installé un
véritable campement ici à bûchel et bien
là c'est l'heure de tout ranger et de
reprendre les tracteurs pour prendre la
direction de rquencour départ prévu aux
environs de 19h30 et on suivra
l'évolution de la situation sur TV 78
avant l'invité du 78 coup d'œil à vos
prévisions météo de
demain les conditions seront brumeuses
demain matin dans les Yvelines la brume
devrait être au moins présente dans le
secteur de Versailles où il fera 4°gr il
fera en moyenne 2°gr sur sur le reste du
territoire dans l'après-midi le le
soleil sera de la partie compté 10°r à
Versailles et Rambouillet jusqu'à 11°gr
à mont-lajolie et Houdan et ce mercredi
31 janvier nous fêterons les marcelles
tout de suite l'invité du
[Musique]
78 l'année 2024 à 50 ans en Eveline tout
au long du mois de janvier les maires de
l'agglomération sont venus sur ce
plateau pour parler des grands projets à
venir dans leur commune ce soir la
dernière de nos interviews et c'est avec
vous Ali Rabet bonsoiroir maire de la
commune de trappe également
vice-président de 50 ans en iveline
délégué à l'économie social et solidaire
bonne année à vous et au trapistes déjà
merci et première question bah qu'est-ce
que vous retenez déjà de l'année 2023
dans votre
commune comme beaucoup de M je crois
qu'on a été marqué et frappé par un
événement celui qui juste avant l'été
à donner une image assez négative de nos
territoire euh ces émeutes qui ont euh
abouti à ce que euh des rues soient
brûlées des équipements publics soient
atteints euh qui a mis nos villes en
émois nos populations en nmois suite à
la mort de naë un jeune homme àanre
rappelez-vous qui a été abattu de son
froid à boutportant par un policier et
cette révolte qui a embrasé le pays qui
a mobilisé toute la génération de naë la
trappe avait été grandement grandement
touché par par ces émeutes est-ce qu'il
y a des choses plus positives quand même
qui sont passé à trrappe en en 2023
heureusement heement heureusement bien
sûr ça a été une année qui a été euh
assez riche en terme de de de
manifestation dans l'espace public en
terme de place de la culture au sein de
la ville de trappe en particulier ça a
été vraiment l'année de monté en
puissance et de mise en œuvre de notre
partenariat avec la Comédie Française je
rappelle que traape est jumelée avec la
Comédie Française pour 3 ans les
trapistes vont régulièrement d'ailleurs
assister à à des représentations c'était
le cas au mois de janvier tout à fait et
puis notamment il y a un moment assez
inoubliable au mois de juin dernier où
la Comédie Française a été tout
simplement privatisée pour les trapistes
et auprès de 1000 trapistes se sont
rendus pour un spectacle de Molière
lavare alors on a vu toutes les
générations les personnes âgées les
jeunes les enfants les mamans tous les
quartiers toutes les couleurs toutes les
tout ce qui fait la richesse de la
population de trappe rentrer au théâtre
dans le plus beau théâtre parisien ça a
été un moment unique inoubliable dans la
vie d'un homme comment vous abordez dans
quel état d'esprit cette année 2024 on
sait une année qui va être marquée
notamment par les les Jeux Olympiques
commune de trappe qui est dans cette
agglomération de 50 ans de vine qui va
accueillir de nombreuses épreuves pour
cesgos la trappe est une ville olympique
en tant que maire à l'au de cesg je peux
pas m'empêcher de me demander si on le
fait souvent avec d'autres élus ou des
responsables de de l'État d'ailleurs si
ces Goos vont profiter à tous je ne veux
surtout pas que ce soit des Jeux
Olympiques qui profitent au touristes
étrangers bien sûr qu'il faut savoir
accueillir mais aux Français les plus
fortunés ceux qui ont les moyens de
s'acheter des billets à plusieurs
centaines d'euros ceux qui ont
l'habitude de jouer au golf ici à
Saint-Quentin à Guill encour mais que ça
profite aussi aux populations local à
ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens aux
enfants dans les écoles que l'esprit
olympique soit partagé à travers des
manifestations qui auront lieu sur notre
territoire on va tâcher d' veiller à
trappe pour que tout le monde en profite
alors dans les grands dossiers 2024 il y
a toujours ce chantier d'envergure alors
qu' n'est pas mené mené directement par
la mairie mais par l'État via la
Direction Régionale des Routes
d'Île-deFrance c'est l'enfouissement
bien sûr de cette national 10 qui va se
poursuivre jusqu'en 2027 l'an passé on a
vu des changements concrets au niveau de
trappe il y a ce giratoire en entrée de
ville il y a aussi un tunnel au niveau
de de cette national 10 qu'on a vu
àaraître qu'est-ce qui est prévu pour
2024 qu'il y a des nouvelles
réalisations qui vont arriver bien sûr
le chantier va continuer à progresser
pour que vous compreniez bien
effectivement il y a eu l'aménagement de
l'entrée de ville c'était le plus
important pour fluidifier la circulation
permettre de diffuser vers Paris hein et
notamment d'avoir cet accès direct
depuis la route de Dreux en souterrain
pour aller vers Paris le matin c'est
quand même très pratique pour éviter les
bouchons en entrée de ville on
continuera avec l'aménagement de deux
voiries provisoires au nord et au sud de
la RN10 qui viendront en fait porter la
la circulation de la route nationale
pendant plusieurs années de chantier le
temps qu'on attaque les tranchées
centrales donc les voitures les routes
par lesquelles aujourd'hui passent les
véhicules vont descendre de plusieurs
mètres jusqu'à 7 m de dénivelé c'est un
chantier pharaonique qui démarrera en
septembre et avant le mois de septembre
et l'attaque des tranchées centrales la
Direction des Routes va préparer
aménager ses voies provisoires qui vont
durer quelques années qui vont être
élargies au nord et au sud de l'irnis Al
dans les dossiers aussi à suivre cette
année à traape il y a ces assises de
l'éducation elles se sont déroulé la
semaine dernière dans la commune en
présence de la communauté éducative de
parents d'élèves de jeunes trapistes
trap fait partie on le rappelle du
dispositif des cités éducatives alors
concrètement c'est pour faire quoi ces
assises de l'éducation ça va aboutir sur
peut-être de nouvelles politiques
attrappe on a la chance d'être la cité
éducative qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'on établit une alliance
entre la mairie l'éducation nationale et
l'État la préfecture pour pouvoir
conjuguer nos force et financer des
projets nouveaux dans nos écoles qui
permettent comme par exemple ce jumelage
avec la Comédie Française d'apporter du
neuf d'apporter de la richesse
culturelle en particulier dans nos
écoles tout ça ça peut pas se faire dans
notre coin entre institutionnel entre
costar cravate comme vous il faut pour
ça inviter ceux qui sont concernés qui
est concerné bah c'est les enseignants
du quotidien ceux qui sont face aux
élèves ce sont les parents d'élèves
également on peut pas considérer qu'on
refait l'école ou la façon de faire
l'école en disant aux parents bah vous
c'est à la maison c'est pas vrai
l'enfant on l'éduque à la maison on
l'éduque à l'école on l'éduque sur les
temps péri scolaire on les dit pendant
les vacances scolaires donc tout le
monde est concerné parents d'élèves
élèves eux-même d'ailleurs quand ils
sont assez grands pour exprimer des
points de vue des propositions et Cera
il en a eu beaucoup d'ailleurs de
proposition ça a été extrêmement riche
franchement on a été débordé par le
succès on pensait pas avoir autant de
monde on a eu plus de 150 participants
180 si ma mémoire est bonne on a rempli
complètement l'amphithéâtre puis surtout
on allit travailler en atelier en table
ronde on est retourné à l'école à 20h le
soir on est parti bosser avec les uns
les autres ça a été très riche très
productif et on a eu un mur de
propositions on est en train d'en faire
la synthèse mais il y a dedans le miel
de l'éducation de demain à trpe ouais
oui il il y a de nouveaux ateliers qui
vont se tenir le but c'est d'aboutir sur
une feuille de route pour la politique
éducative àrape ex c'est pas s'arrêter
là donc c'est ça a été une première
amorce il y aura trois réunions par
groupe de travail on a eu une centaine
d'inscrits pour continuer le travail sur
le long terme avec nous et nous
accompagner pour façonner ses
propositions les construire les mettre
en œuvre et l'objectif c'est dans
quelques mois d'être capable de dire
voilà la feuille de route élaboré avec
les habitants et maintenant à nous de
nous mettre au travail et de nous
remonter les manches pour que ça
devienne une réalité alors puisqu'on
parle des écoles la ville a inauguré l'
passé une première cours écologique
inclusive et non genré c'était à l'école
jeanmassé est-ce que vous pouvez déjà
rappeler le principe pourquoi la commune
mèent ses travaux est-ce qu'il y en a
des nouveaux qui sont programmés pour
cette année bien sûr alors les cours
d'école c'est vraiment un espace
important parce que non seulement c'est
un temps de repos un temps de récréation
pour les élèves mais c'est aussi
aujourd'hui malheureusement un O à
l'heure dans la plupart des écoles de
France c'est-à-dire un lieu où on
étouffe un lieu où on a rarement l'ombre
d'un arbre et où on a une air de jeu qui
végète au milieu de la cour de
récréation si ce n'est pas tout
simplement un terrain de foot qui prend
tout l'espace euh la cour d'école c'est
un lieu qui doit permettre de lutter
contre les discriminations entre les
garçons et les filles les garçons qui
prennent tout l'espace les filles qui
sont reléguées au marge la cour d'école
ça doit être un espace ou pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs on enseigne pendant l'été
quand on subit des pics de canicules et
que nos écoles surchauff et qu'on puisse
aller à l'ombre d'un arbre dans des
espaces prévus pour ça pour donner une
heure de cours en permettant au All de
se rafraîchir la cour d'école c'est un
lieu où on évite les le harcèlement on
évite que les enfants soient stigmatisés
abandonnés isolés tout seul donc ça se
construit ça se débitume j'en ai marre
moi de ces espèces d'océan de bitume
dans lesquels nos enfants essayent de de
surnager donc on va on a fait des cours
d'école avec beaucoup de terre beaucoup
d'arbres beaucoup de plantations avec
des aires de jeu imaginé par les enfants
avec des coposs de bois avec des
matériaux qui sont beaucoup plus
chaleureux c'est un succès immense
puisque cette école Jean Massé qui a
fait qui a été la première équipé en
cours oasis elle l' été sur un projet
qui a été dessiné par les élèves et les
parents et les enseignants pas par le
maire de trappe j'ai aucune compétence
en la matière et puis je passe pas
beaucoup de temps dans les cours d'école
donc on a demandé à ceux qui l'utilisent
de la dessiner et puis on fera pareil
donc le résultat c'est que dans quelques
années on aura plus que des cours
d'école oisis si je ne veux plus
entendre parler des anciennes cours
d'école et aucune école ne remble aucune
cours ne ressemblera à l'autre elles
seront toutes un peu uniques sur mesure
dessiné par ceux qui les utilisent alors
un mot rapide sur des chantiers qui vont
aboutir aussi cette année celui du
grenacel on va pouvoir de nouveau se
payer une toile au grenier à sel dès
cette année àrappe et aussi du nouveau
concernant les planetes Pergo c'est bien
ça exactement pour le grenier à cel
c'est il avait besoin d'un coup de
rafraîchissement le bâtiment il a 500
ans donc c'est un bâtiment exceptionnel
historique dont on veut préserver le
patrimoine qu'il constitue pour la ville
de trappe mais on a surtout voulu
améliorer le confort intérieur donc
vraiment les usagers les trapistes vont
découvrir un théâtre un cinéma pardon
complètement neuf beaucoup plus
confortable beaucoup plus attirant alors
ça va être notre façon de faire
concurrence à l'UGC de 50 ans éeline
pour l'esplanade Pergo c'est un espace
public qui est vraiment au carrefour de
plusieurs quartiers des quartiers
sociaux des quartiers d'habitat social
des quartiers de propriétaires privés
tout près de la base de loisirs tout
près de la passerelle qui permet
d'accéder à la base de loisirs et
l'enjeu c'est d'en faire un lieu de
rencontre un lieu de brassage un lieu de
mixité ce qui est vraiment mon obsession
moi je pense que les populations dans
notre pays et dans ma ville en
particulier doivent se mélanger qu'on
est plus heureux comme ça quand on se
connaît quand on se croise quand nos
enfants jouent dans les mêmes aires de
jeu et donc on va aménager on a aménager
on est en train de la livrer une place
et un espace extraordinaire avec des
jeux pour tous les âges depuis les tout
petits les nourrissons à peine nés avec
des aires de jeu dédié pour les 03 ans
jusqu'aux personnes âgées qui trouveront
à s'épanouir notamment grâce au jardin
potager de 600 m² qui va être mise à
disposition donc on ver aboutir ce
chantier cette année à trappe alors
autre nouveauté c'est la mise en place
d'un budget participatif la mairie
consacre 320000 € sur quel type de
projet on pourra avoir ce ce budget
participatif utilisé justement on a plus
de 90 projets qui ont été déposés ce qui
est super pour une première édition en
déposer dans les il reste quelques jours
là pour pouvoir déposer son projet après
la mairie doit rentrer dans une phase
d'étude de faisabil de chacun de ces
projets est-ce qu'on parle du territoire
qui appartient à la ville à
l'agglomération au département est-ce
qu'on a le droit de le faire est-ce
qu'on a pas le droit de le faire et
d'évaluation des coûts également on
s'est dit que la démocratie c'est pas
juste on vote une fois tous les 6 ans et
puis après on fait confiance au ma faut
faire confiance au mare s'il fait du bon
boulot sinon faut lui demander de partir
mais je pense que le maire doit donner
de la place aux habitants pour prendre
des décisions c'est à la fois bah donner
son avis sur la courasis j'en parlais
tout à l'heure mais c'est aussi pouvoir
se dire nous habitants du quartier on
s'organise dans l'assemblée citoyenne du
quartier on en a mis en place une
dizaine sur la ville et on s'organise on
débat on discute de nos préoccupations
et on fait des propositions et on porte
nous-même le projet on sait pas le maire
qui fera pour nous qui réfléchira pour
nous à notre place c'est nous-même qui
sommes capables parce qu'on nous a donné
un budget donc je partage une partie du
budget d'investissement de la mairie ben
on est souverain on est capable de
décider que ce sera tel projet en votant
pour les projets qui doit être mis en
œuvre en 2024
2025 ça voudra dire par exemple aménager
un un petit square de proximité pour les
gamins ça peut être améliorer la
sécurité de d'une
d'une rue qui pose des difficultés ça
peut être organiser des manifestations
d'ampleur sur le quartier c'est aux
habitants de déterminer ce qui leur
tient à cœur moi je trouve que dans les
premiers projets que j'ai analysé je
trouve que c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est la volonté de mettre en place des
projets écolo à des projets qui
permettent le partage je parlais de
jardin partagé ça revient souvent
planter des arbres être capable de
s'engager dans la transition écolo c'est
vraiment dans les projets spontanément
proposé c'est revenu régulièrement et je
prends vraiment ça comme une bonne
nouvelle parce que c'était pas forcément
très attendu de ma part alors pour
terminer abé il nous reste moins d'une
minute on vous donne une carte blanche
un sujet de votre choix qui vous tient à
cœur c'est à vous pour l'aborder écoutez
on avait un sujet juste avant l'émission
sur les agriculteurs et la colère des
agriculteurs peut-être en dir un mot
rapidement pour dire que je suis frappé
que dans notre pays ceux qui nous
nourrissent ceux qui sont chargés de
nous assurer la souveraineté sur le plan
alimentaire ne puissent pas se nourrir
eux-même et se servir un revenu décent
et la façon dont les agriculteurs se
mobilisent et dénoncent quelque chose
auquel moi je crois depuis des années
que je dénonce depuis des années
c'est-à-dire une forme de concurrence
déloyale qui oppose les travailleurs
français qu'il soient agriculteur ou
qu'il travaillent dans les usines avec
des produits importés de l'autres bout
du monde fabriqué parfois par des
enfants ou dans des conditions pour ce
qui concerne les produits agricoles qui
ne respectent pas les normes que nous
nous imposons ici les normes
environnementales les normes sur le
travail justement des enfants ou pas sur
je trouve que c'est immoral et la force
avec laquelle les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui s'expriment ça doit être
celle qui doit nous mobiliser tous nous
concerner tous pour ouvrir les yeux sur
le fait qu'un libre échange aveugle
complètement responsable qui organise la
concurrence déloyale du fort contre le
faible qui fait rentrer le renard dans
le poulailler c'est plus supportable et
qu'il faut se donner les moyens de
protéger notre économie de protéger
notre agriculture de protéger notre
industrie pour qu'en Europe et en France
en particulier on maintienne de l'emploi
et on se donne les moyens de survivre et
de vivre décemment merci al ARB d'avoir
été avec nous je le rappelle maire de la
commune de trappe une nouvelle fois
bonne année à vous et à tous les
Trappistes et c'est la fin du 78 merci
de nous avoir suivi demain pour une
nouvelle édition vous retrouverez
Mathilde Francou à la présence belle
soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78